mark I'm not gonna let you sit down and
get comfortable who was that dude at the
very end of the trailer that we saw
Donald Trump no he's he's a new
character
um he's our big bad for the year we call
him prometheus that said before you
start typing and blogging and everything
it's not the Grant Morrison Howard
Porter Prometheus from Justice League
just straight up but his new character
someone who fits into the theme of
legacy this year that is going to be
driving all of our characters quite
frankly including The Big Bad so he's
pretty badass and mean nice I like that
obviously Oliver is thinking a lot about
his legacy he's forming a new team
something that Laurel really inspired
him to do Wendy why was that such a
great idea to sort of frame the
beginning at least of the season around
I think we really wanted to honor what
we'd done last season and obviously with
Laurel being gone it's incredibly
important for Oliver and the rest of the
team to move forward remembering that
legacy and honoring it absolutely I know
I speak for the fans when I say that we
miss Katie Cassidy all the time she is
incredible why are the chances we may
see her again well we will definitely
see her in 501 and our premiere season
and we have made a deal with her across
arrow flash and legend so Katie Cassidy
is definitely not gone from this
universe nice
Stephen at the end of last season
Felicity said to Oliver you know you're
at war with these two sides of yourself
he had really sort of done a lot of
things that made him question himself
what excites you about going into this
new year sort of with this version of
Oliver syndication syndication no I'm
very excited because you know there was
the this one extreme of Oliver that we
saw in season one and then a very
reactionary version of Oliver that we
saw in season two after the death of
Tommy and
what we see now with Oliver is we see in
Oliver that that understands that it's
not just black and white that there are
shades of gray and he's really back to
the mission of first and foremost the
most important thing in my life is
honoring what my father asked me to do
is protecting Star City and I feel like
that has I've been saying all day today
this certainly I don't think is the last
year of the show but it's definitely the
end of a chapter and that is this was
conceived as a five year journey
so both Oliver in the present and in the
flashbacks I feel like if we do this
you're right we will have the ability to
then start anew cool yeah I like that I
mean speaking of syndication you guys
will hit the hundredth episode this year
which is huge and very very cool mark
can you talk a little bit about like
what kind of conversations have you guys
in the writers room been having about
what to do with that hundredth episode
well you know it's interesting our
hundredth episode is 508 turns out 508
will be chapter two of our three-part
crossover so the hundredth episode is
going to be the middle part of the cross
over and then episode knives our
mid-season finale so we're we're kind of
designing things to be like a hundred
two episode hundredth episode
celebration the bigness of our mega
crossover and the bigness of our
mid-season family so it's actually timed
kind of perfectly nice I like that
Emily first of all hi happy early
birthday he wanted you any your uh it
was a really eventful season for
Felicity last year she got shot she
battled her alter ego got self she
defeated Abby robot person
she lost a friend yes all of those
things uh what excites you about the
version of felicity you get to bring
into this new year
um I am excited to explore her story the
Syrian girls gonna be dealing with a lot
of bottled up emotions unfortunately and
she's gonna work through them I think
we're going to do it quite
I see honestly as a selfish point I
always like to play the comedy and those
sort of things but I don't think that
would be totally if I just asked for
playing that respectful of her journey
coming up because she's holding on to
this guilt of killing 10,000 people the
lesser of two evils
so yeah she's just gonna be dealing with
that and hopefully doing it with a smile
but I bet you went to the lone she's got
some rabbit ears going down there stand
about I mean speaking of Paul you know
Quentin went through a really huge loss
last year you know he not only lost his
daughter he lost his job I mean he left
with the love of his life or the now
what could possibly bring him back to
this town I have no idea haha I mean God
it's becoming a habit losing a daughter
you know through it three times now um
yeah it's uh pretty that's pretty rough
wait guys write this stuff for this guy
get a break at least he got laid last
season laughs that was nice
that really was the only such a shining
light wasn't it haha
it makes the the grief and good news
work but um chakras one of these guys
muttering down the panel here well the
last go late we just thinks didya
awesome that he got laid we really did
right totally thank you that was yard
play for the whole thing that was the
oldest relationship in the history of
the CW haha yeah probably uh but um no
Lance is utterly miserable coming back
into season five having said all that
some old demons haunting him and yeah
trying to pick up the pieces of lost
family his guilt and everything that's
involved with that with Laurel and no
job I think somebody said when he did
when he picked up you and your dad that
time in the car somebody said Oh Lance
lost his job as he's a new uber driver
now ha ha ha ha ha and I think that's
the future for Lance this is whether you
guys ever see it my back story is he's
an uber driver
the thing paradox changed you into a
goober driver I hate to break it I hate
to break it to Paul it's lift lift more
a reasonable option okay but you
moonlight doing post mates they're just
helping helping however he can just like
Oliver David I'm curious you know Diggle
also left town at the end of the seasons
really a lot of stuff weighing on him
then we heard in the previous panel that
Diggle is sort of the one who's going to
be affected by the flashpoint that
happened on the did you hear them I mean
we all heard it you guys heard it right
we were there way up yeah I'm just I'm
just relaying information yeah I mean
what can you tell us about Diggle at the
start of season five um he's in Chechnya
and he's an uber driver hahaha um
that's great you look good anyway no
he's not he's not he's not any Chechnya
um where did you get that one from cuz
he actually isn't checking you okay he's
in Chechnya he's uh with the Special
Forces handling some business over there
he's still a man of two minds to a great
degree he misses the team but um he's
still dealing with the tragic death of
Black Canary who he obviously he blames
himself of that and why he pulled the
trigger and killing his brother he's
still dealing with that and we deal with
that in a very very visceral way there's
a great scene we just shot with Diggle
and how he deals with the death of his
of his brother and his involvement with
that so he's very much at the beginning
of season 2 my Z's he still conflicted
about the events of season 5 cool I like
that well echo I would like to say
welcome to the family
thank y'all can go with the stage haha
Curtis is I almost said terrific I
actually I'm laughing manically said
terrific and that would have been the
loop uh we watched you in that trailer
tackle the Salmon Ladder try to tell
them a letter I mean is that okay so how
much of what we see in that is genuine
effort and how much of it is just oh you
know for this because what was it was
what scripted that he wasn't supposed to
be good at know that thing is uh super
hard kudos to Stephen for now
knocking it out non-stop um but yeah you
know I think Curtis is just really like
influenced by green arrow
you know he really looks up to him and
you know he really wants to get out
there and help Star City as much as
again like him and it's a struggle and I
think that I'm a fighter struggling and
mark we're gonna get a lot of his
backstory this year right we're gonna
get like an origin story we're gonna
find out a lot more about Curtis this
year yeah actually we've got some pretty
big plans for Curtis especially with
respect to his marriage you know he you
know he's gonna as you sort of saw he is
he wants to become a vigilante and he
wants to start fighting crime at the
same time he's got this husband at home
who is gonna probably start to notice
that he's coming home with all these
bruises and cuts and that's gonna it's
gonna you know it's gonna raise some
questions and we're really looking
forward to watching
Curtis try to answer him Lewis so I'm
just seeing John's face about the
gruesome easy for John underhanded pick
she just threw mark on the head yeah uh
Willa I'm curious you know you your
character left also sort of the the
banshee was like I'm done with this and
we sort of see a begrudging Thea in the
trailer sort of doesn't really want to
be back in the costume I mean how do you
describe her attitude towards this
endeavor when we come back well I think
that uh he has definitely gone through a
lot in the last obviously four seasons
totaling but in the last season she went
through everything from being drugged by
her father again being stuck in an arc
losing her basically pseudo sister
putting on a real cool costume but then
also being struck by this bloodlust
ething and then killing people all the
time and then stopping doing that and
then holding a knife to a little girl's
throat and realizing that it's not the
blud loves doing that to her was
actually just her so I think she just
needs to like take a step back for a
second and wise realize what's going on
and like her own psyche and maybe like
do something that's like structurally
good for her and maybe Star City which
is probably helping out all Eason sees
mayor like if you had given all over
that pitch as opposed to just being like
I'm going to leave he would have totally
gotten it yeah haven't you been paying
attention what's goin on bro no I think
this this year she's gonna be doing a
lot of stuff helping out Oliver Li like
she has done in the last season but in a
different way since now he's not
necessarily a mayor moonlighting as a
vigilante as you guys so nicely wrote he
is a vigilante moonlighting as the mayor
at the moment so someone's gonna need to
do some duties in the city
Sivan let's talk about that I mean you
know your honor or whatever your formal
title is as you get into a mayor mr.
mayor mr. mayor
sure thank you uh what do you think
about Oliver in this capacity what a
garbage mayor he is he's terrible and
he's terrible because he is alone
there's no team so all of his focus and
all of his energy is going into being
the green arrow being a vigilante trying
to stop crime within the city and Thea
is carrying all the water as mayor
basically and so you know I he ran for
mayor and was I guess kind of elected as
mayor for excellent reasons but those
reasons have gotten lost in the shuffle
a little bit so hopefully he rediscovers
them because I really like the idea I
know that you know longtime fans of
green arrow know what a what a
politically inspired character Oliver
Queen is and he had a he had a point of
view he had an ideology and I think all
of those things would be very
interesting to explore on the show so
he'll have to get his head out of his
you-know-what and start working well
with others which probably will never
happen so but I like the idea of him as
a mayor very cool yeah
I mean speaking of you know starting a
team John it looks like Malcolm is going
to have some new people that he's going
to start working with you're going to be
sort of spread over all of the shows
what excites you about getting to bring
Malcolm to all of those different worlds
well the the first thing is that you
know all was true to where he was born
in that sense is the character which is
this show but he's the the bad guy that
I always say he's a troubled hero a hero
of his own story and what will be
interesting is to see what he is like in
these other if I can say time yeah lines
yeah yeah
no use the new the new map the new
different Malcolm's because who's to say
where he may pop up and I'm being very
cautious about what I'm saying cuz I
don't want to say anything I'm not
supposed to but if he is on legend where
what time might that be where in the
story there he might be if that makes
any sense is it the past is it the
future is it the present he might behave
differently it might be an alternate
side to him so that's what I'm really
excited about as an actor I know listen
listen I've time traveled before I know
what it's all about
hahahahahaha
I know how I know how to follow the
story and put it all together trust me
but uh it sounds confusing but I'm
excited as an actor to be able to play
those different things yeah and that to
me is what's going to be exciting but
the the fact is that you know this is
the core of where and it's funny to hear
Stephen speak at like Oliver being the
bad man
Malcolm's always a phone call away it's
true he's always all the way and good
for my girl taking on the lead yeah I
like that I'm gonna open it up to the
audience questions in just a minute so
if you want to get ready I solicited
questions for this panel from Twitter
and oh dear God and I know it's gonna
come as a huge surprise to everyone that
the predominant question had something
to do with a little thing called olicity
first things first I'm congratulations
Stephen and Emily on winning ship of the
year for the second year in a row at the
MTV fandom Awards voted on by you guys
thank thanks to all the fans online and
work really really hard to make that
happen
that's I nine point six million votes
that's great that's amazing uh mark
Wendy when we left the two of them they
were sort of together but not together
how do you describe the status of this
relationship at the start of season five
it's still a partnership I mean the way
we left them in the bunker at the end
the last season was somewhat ambiguous
and we will kick them off in a similarly
ambiguous state that said you will find
out some more and right around Episode
five and I think you know we're just
going to let the characters kind of take
us where they will absolutely I mean
Stephen Oliver obviously kept some
things from her last year there was some
maybe some amazing mistakes I don't know
I mean what do you guys think about what
should happen with the couple what would
you like to see do you like what you're
getting to play right now sort of the in
betweenness very much so we have a
really dynamic scene in the in the
premiere where we speak to each other as
equals as team members you know I've
always thought that Oliver's most
important relationship in arrow is his
relationship to Star City and his love
of that city
and that is the main objective at this
time in his life I think it's pretty
clear that he Oliver loves Felicity but
I don't know if that means they're gonna
be together but I really like the scene
that we had in the pilot Emily and I
like high-fived after yes we were fired
up you know like it's not transform we
didn't know it was going there and I
feel like there Felicity and Oliver's
communication and collaboration aspects
of themselves are just getting stronger
as teammates and that's that's a good
thing and obviously as we saw on legends
of tomorrow you know smoke technologies
exist in 2046 so she's got some work to
do awesome
you